here I'll tell you how I got sober man
let's just we'll get into it you know
I've been talking about it for a while
there's never really like a right time
to talk about that sort of thing but I
do want to be able to share it with you
guys because sometimes people ask about
it and wonder what's up and then you
know I'll just tell you how I got into
that so you know I was born I was born
my father was an old man my dad was 70
years old when I was born and my mother
was 32 and and they had four children
and you know when I was born I think
there was some shame or uncertainty by
my parents they had me call my dad by
his first name instead of calling him
dad because I guess maybe they'd gotten
a lot of you know strange looks from
people or or judgment and maybe they
felt like that was a way that wouldn't
make it easier on them and maybe on us
too but my father was very old when I
was born and as I started to get to know
him I was just kind of scared because
you know he was a senior citizen in and
he was just kept getting older like as I
was getting older he was getting older
and I remember you know when he wouldn't
go on and walk in a church one time and
I had to like walk him like make sure he
was okay where he was stepping and uh
you know just what the concrete was like
and so he didn't you know trip and that
sort of thing and so it just made me I
think hyper aware when I was really
young I was very aware and my mother
worked a lot and and she wasn't really
connected to me you know she just worked
a lot and she had to work you know she
had four children and my parents got
divorced and we lived in like up and we
moved to like a poor area and
and I guess I just started to feel like
ashamed you know I felt ashamed of the
fact that my family was poor I felt
ashamed that my dad was old and couldn't
you know couldn't be like as much a part
of my life in a lot of ways because
physically it was hampering to him and
then because my parents were separated
and then he wasn't around and you know I
and I started making up stories and I
would tell people stories to make my
life different than it was you know I
would tell people you know I would take
the school bus sometimes to a different
neighborhood and get dropped off and
then walk because I didn't want people
to see where I lived and I would we
started riding my bike to school I'd
ride my bike maybe five miles to school
when I was in middle school you know and
that's fifth grade and maybe that's not
wild but at the time it didn't feel wild
to me you know it felt like this is what
I need to do to feel okay
so you know my peers won't judge me or
and they may not even have been judging
me I just felt I don't know I guess I
just felt judged I felt less than I felt
I don't know honestly I didn't know
sometimes I didn't really feel anything
but I knew that if I showed up at school
on the poor bus then people knew I was
poor and and and I already felt bad
enough because nobody was telling me in
my world like one of my parents that I
could feel okay about myself you know I
didn't have my you know there wasn't a
father around and this isn't a sob story
I'm trying to tell you guys I'm trying
to tell you how I ended up getting into
a Alcoholics Anonymous for me I'm not
saying you need to do this I don't know
your life I don't know your world if you
were doing an eight ball right now and
listen
this bra and eating you know and eating
somebody's butt you matter whatever do
your thing I'm not judging you at all
man I wish I was right there with you
one day I may be back but for now this
is where I am so I just felt you know I
just felt less than I felt I didn't I
didn't know anything about myself how to
feel good about myself so the only way I
knew to feel good was if I could make
you like me I needed like I needed you I
only decided how I felt based on how you
felt about me and it went from moment to
moment and so I was a storyteller
because I wanted my life to be different
to other people and so I told stories
and and also I like to make him people
laugh because I knew that if they were
laughing then they they they were okay
with me you know that it they couldn't
be hating me and laugh and at the same
time my sister I had a younger sister
who was very ill she was born with a
rare liver disease and she needed a
liver transplant upon her birth and so
when my mother did have free time a lot
of time my sister got the affection
because she was ill and she got a lot
more love and affection than my brothers
and sister my other brother and my other
sister did I felt like anyhow I was you
know growing up and one thing I really
loved was summertime I would go to YMCA
summer camp and at summer camp
things weren't as clicky everybody was
on the same page it was it was a group
of kids in the summer that just wanted
to have fun we got to do fun stuff we
all you know rode on a bus together from
the camp to go to field trips and I just
loved that
and you know our and and and people
didn't adjust this wasn't as judgmental
you know my mom would drop us off there
and we'd stay there and go to summer
camp and we weren't it just felt like
less judgment and one day I was um I was
walking in my neighborhood and one of
the counselors from my summer camp drove
down the street he was happen to be
driving through my neighborhood and he
saw me in this neighborhood and there
was uh you know our neighborhood was
poor man it was you know I think it was
the poorest white neighborhood that was
around us I felt like and that and then
when I saw him at summer camp he was
joking with some of the other counselors
he was making fun of where I lived he
was making fun of you know he was making
fun of the place he saw me run out of
the apartment I ran out of and and it
just at that point like a lot something
inside of me just really kind of died
something you know like here was this
one place where I really felt kind of
okay and now that place didn't feel okay
to me anymore
so you know so high school went on and
God gave me some good gifts and I was a
storyteller and you know I was always
concerned though like you know always
needed to be around more people or
everything was always started to be you
know we need to change this we need to
do that I go to a party and then I have
to go to another part like where's the
party where we're at the party something
never felt kind of okay I just never
felt okay I always felt like I was
trying to make things okay and things
weren't bad I had some great times I was
fun I was having fun but on the inside I
was I didn't know who I was at all I
didn't have any beliefs I didn't have
any real values
and how I felt about me was based upon
how you felt about me when I was 14 I
got emancipated you know I couldn't live
at my family's home anymore my brother
had moved away to live with my
grandparents and he and I weren't close
and and I and after he'd moved away you
know I bet I'd spent a lot of time in
our room by myself and it made me I
think real sad cuz my brother's bed was
in there and my bed was in there
you know in every kind of like year
every six months he would say you know
and my mom would say he might come back
and live with us again and he didn't
come back you know and I don't fault him
for it or anything he you know he had
his own walk with our environment and he
needed to find a place for him to be
well and and he's gotten very well over
the years and uh and anyhow so but it
all like I was just in this room and I
wanted things to be different and I was
a scared kid you know and this before I
moved out of my mother's home and I just
remember being really scared I wanted to
I remember being at night they uh you
know our neighborhood was scary
and it was just we grew up like it was
you know kind of poor white and poor
black was like right over from us and it
was just you know it was scary when
people get real impoverished like things
get scary and I was just scared and at
night I would do it I was a scared kid I
remember like I would wet the bed all
the time you know and I remember I
remember there was a mom one time when I
was young I heard that if I animal had
urinated somewhere that other animals
couldn't come get that animal and so I
remember at that point sometimes I would
urinate off my bed around my bed in a
big circle at night so that things
couldn't come get me you know I was just
creating this crazy like world inside of
me there was a lot of fear and there was
a lot of uncertainty and there was not
a lot of systems inside of myself to
make myself feel okay and my mother and
I were just disconnected man you know
she gave us birthdays and she gave us
holidays but she had to work hard and I
think that she you know I don't know I
don't know if she had the tools really
to make me feel loved you know so anyhow
I got emancipated at fourteen I ended up
living with the family for the first
time I had my own room and I had peace I
had some peace in my life I mean just
like moments rod just felt like I could
relax a little bit but this but this
thing inside of me of not feeling okay
was still very much there and you know I
developed issues with women where you
know I had a really tough time relating
to women and entrusting women and
feeling okay and and really being able
to commit to relationships and at some
point you know life went on things were
going okay but I started using at some
point cocaine a little bit and I liked
cocaine because I would get it and do it
by myself at home at night and I would
just do it it and it just made me feel
good and enough to be around other
people and I don't know it just made me
feel something it made me feel something
I mean for so long inside of myself I'd
had so many years really of creating my
own feelings on the outside of me but
not really having them inside of me you
know like I just didn't have feeling and
inside like I just if I wanted to feel
something I had to think it up and then
act it out and display it as I'd seen it
displayed and like television or movies
are from others but the inside of me
there wasn't a lot going on so anyhow
like the you know and I wasn't getting
crazy into drugs or anything like that
but I had one night where I ended up in
a taxi cab and a woman said something to
me kind of rejected me in like a mean
way and I hadn't done anything wild I
just you know had
you know I you know express some
interest and she expressed interest and
then I returned the expression and then
she was mean to me and she didn't reject
me rejections fine but she was mean to
me also and next thing you know the taxi
driver dropped her off we were in the
taxi and next thing you know I end up
with the taxi driver four hours later me
and him are doing cocaine together and
and I'm driving the taxi and he's in the
back he's in the back with an escort
he bought me an escort I don't want no
escort you know luigi that was the guy's
name and we're in North Harlem and I'm
driving a taxi and the meter is still
running I'm still paying for that taxi
and uh and that morning I was in New
York because I had to be on I was in New
York I had to be on a big radio show
called the Opium Jim Norton radio show
and they had like a million listeners
and it was a huge opportunity and if
you'd asked me the night before hey man
he's gonna stay up all night partying
before you go into the radio I'd have
said no way I would never do that and
then here I was in this moment and it's
5:00 a.m. I got to go to the radio you
know I mean I got to my hotel after
driving taxi and then paying for it dude
just blown out of my mind dude I
couldn't feel my face with either hand
at first I thought something was rolling
my hands but then I realized something
wrong my face
and
and I get to the radio station yet I
took three showers in ten minutes before
I went there so you know you want some
really you know some belt dust if you're
taking three showers in ten minutes
and drying off between each one and
that's cocaine Papa and I get to the
radio station and the other guests and I
can't even talk and and the other guest
for the day was Darryl Strawberry who
was a Hall of Fame baseball player and
he's even look him up and he's one of
the greatest baseball players ever but
he his career was really altered by
cocaine and here he was I was on the
radio with him I had it collected his
cards when I was young and I couldn't
even talk the main gift that God had
given me was my voice and I couldn't
even use it because I've been up all
night just using drugs to feel good
somehow our using drugs to feel anything
and and that was crazy because I always
thought in my head Oh Darryl Strawberry
you think you thought about him and you
thought oh he's on drugs he's this and
that he ruined his life but then here he
was in front him he was 13 years sober
he was eloquent successful and I mean he
was a Dan King sitting in front of me
and at one moment that's where some
things lined up in my life that's where
some things lined up in my mind and said
oh hey look here you are with this gift
you think you have that you can
communicate you can't even talk because
you [ __ ] up brah because you've been
out of driving taxi and here you are
with somebody who you thought or had
judged as being [ __ ] up and here he is
a king and it just lined things up in a
perfect moment where I just had this
moment of like oh I need to something
needs to change for me and the next day
I was back in Los Angeles I was telling
that same story to someone and they said
hey man I go to these meetings you know
I go to meetings and so then I went to
some AAA meetings and
you know and for the first time in my
life I sat down and listened to people
tell stories which were my favorite
thing to hear my whole life I've been
loving stories man I love your story you
know whatever your story is I love it
man I look because all my life when I
was young I just won in a different
story
I wanted a different story whether I had
to tell it or try and live yours whether
I had to get emancipated and come live
at your house or this house or that
house I just wanted a different story
man I wanted to be I wanted to be in a
family and I wanted to feel loved you
know
you know I just really I mean I think
and I didn't even know it I didn't know
how much I wanted to how much I wanted
to be loved
man I just didn't even know it and once
I got into these rooms I could you had
to sit there you had to be quiet and you
had to hear other people and people
started talking and telling their
stories and for the first time in my
life they were telling emotional like
tales of that were exciting and [ __ ]
dope and like deep and real and I
connected that with that I loved it you
know I loved it in that and so I'll just
kept going I just kept going and next
thing you know I was like next thing you
know I had a couple nights in a row or a
couple weeks in a row or months in a row
while I was spending time with other
people and I was meeting people and I
and like suddenly Los Angeles became
like this place that I'd always kind of
hated and judged it became a little bit
I still don't like that place people out
of their [ __ ] minds out there wants a
disconnected kook's judging most of the
the rest of America
but it also made me it gave me a place
to kind of it just gave me friends it
gave me people and because I know those
people had had struggles I knew that
they'd felt some of the same ways that I
felt inside
I couldn't judge those people you know
even though sometimes I wanted to you
know you never do come in and like you
know and you know he'd lost his family
or he you know he he'd lost his kids and
been taken away by the courts and he's
drinking or a woman who'd addicted to
heroin and she you know hadn't seen and
finally they're getting their lives back
together and you just you know they say
like listen for the similarities not the
differences and I always want my life
sometimes I'd always wanted to listen
for differences because differences gave
me an ability to separate me from other
people and if I'm just me by myself then
I know that I'm I'm okay because it's
the only thing I've ever known the only
way I've ever been okay really is by
being by myself
I don't know an okay where I'm attached
to others you know where I trust others
that like a place deeper than my own
feelings a place that I don't really
know but for the first time in these
rooms I could do it you know for the
first time in these rooms like I started
like man I had love for people that
didn't even know and then in moments and
still this stuff kind of comes slow but
I start to have love for myself you know
and the hardest thing for me to do in my
life has been to love myself because you
know somewhere in my life and my story
or when I was young or I don't know when
you know I think just because of you
know maybe my you know damn being so old
and you know my mom not feeling like my
mother cared about me or whatever it's
not a sob story I'm not telling you that
but I'm just telling you that I'd never
really loved myself because
I'd never really loved myself because uh
somewhere in my past in like a long time
before that
I guess I you know I just had felt like
I wasn't worth it you know and it's a
it's tough to kind of admit some of that
but uh and it wasn't a choice I made
even like consciously it's not like
somebody said hey are you worth loving
yourself I would have said yes but
somewhere deeper than that like
somewhere when I was young or when I
don't know but just somewhere before
that you know I just decided that I
wasn't you know I just looked at my
surroundings and I don't know I just had
felt or my life or whatever the recipe
was that was in my life I looked at that
and um and I was like oh yeah
yeah you're not you don't deserve or
you're not good or you're bad you're a
bad person or something I don't know
I still don't know you know there's
still a lot for me to learn anyway this
story's a little bit emotional for me
but you know it's this is the story that
I tell and so since I got an in to going
to meetings and stuff like that and look
I wasn't a coke head I have friends at
our Co kids I expand I mean my coke use
was probably it was over a couple years
maybe once every few months maybe three
times a year four times a year but then
there was a point over about three weeks
or maybe six weeks I don't know where it
had escalated and it was just kind of
like it was like once a week and then it
was like you know the last two weeks it
was like two or three times a week you
know I mean I'm pissed sometimes I'm
like look I wish I never even got to
smoke crack you know I don't want to be
a crackhead but [ __ ] you know I'll tell
you no I'll take a hit or two just to
see it you know what everybody's talking
about down at the bus at the are down at
the Greyhound you know but since then
you know in this program I've learned
like
you know I've just I don't feel it alone
I don't feel as alone as I used to and
I'm learning to have different feelings
about myself and different ways to think
about myself and it's a program of
action though like I have to work and I
have to let go to you know some of these
meetings and I go to the meetings man
it's so funny that God used or my higher
power people say higher power God
whatever you know I believe in God I
believe in God you know it's so much out
here in like this business I mean they
try to like make you feel like you it's
not cool to do that but I'm not gonna
feel that way for me because I need that
you know in the program too that you
know the a a it's cool because they it's
not about the drugs and alcohol man you
know I never liked drinking I know I was
never you know it's never a pothead I
was never I just started to see like oh
man if you to ask me one day will you go
to this great opportunity you have on
this radio station with you know one of
the biggest radio stations that radio
shows in the world would you go on that
[ __ ] up how to said no way and then
here I was doing something that I
wouldn't have done so that's when I
realized like you know I just wasn't I
wasn't even doing things that I really
wanted to be doing and now my life has
gotten better man it really has and
sometimes I only want to admit that you
know there's something inside of me
sometimes that wants to make me separate
from other people you know there's
something that wants to make me alone
because it's part of the only way that I
ever knew how to be
and man it has been a journey
nothing withdrew the drugs are not
called again whatever you know I may get
a you know I may I don't know if I'll
always be sober I have no idea but the
thing that keeps me involved is man I
get I get to learn so much about myself
about loving others about acceptance
it's introduced me to other issues that
I have that you know maybe drugs and
alcohol and even my issue it's just
introduced me into a world of like
introspection like for the first time I
can take a look at myself and uh and I
still look I got a ton of faults I'm not
but I know that if I stay like on this
path that things can get better I
believe that because there's proof for
me you know my career has gotten better
you know I've met people that have loved
me you know I've been I've been in and
out of a relationship with somebody that
loved me you know for one of the first
times in my life that I really felt that
not that other people hadn't loved me in
the past but this was the first time I
could feel it you know and it's just
because something had changed inside of
me where
you know where I didn't need to just
have all these walls up or whatever to
survive anymore like you know I think my
higher power wants to tell me look man
you're going to be okay you know you can
take a break
you know and uh anyway you know I don't
know um you know I don't know if I'll
always be a part of this program or not
but you know for the first time I
lifelike this story like that's a you
know I can tell you a true story you
know all the years of like having a line
like you know be ashamed of who I was or
what I was or anything or anything like
that like it's still okay to tell
stories okay to create and be you know I
want to bring people together and and be
a storyteller and think about things and
that's all okay but for the first time I
life I have a little bit of a story of
my own you know and there are moments
you know not always but there's moments
ronald feels ashamed of myself as i did
for so long man you know I was so
ashamed I was so ashamed of myself for
things I don't need nothing really for
nothing just because at a young age and
nobody had told me not to be ashamed of
myself
you know nobody had told me hey man
you're OK
you know nobody had told me hey man you
are ok and you're not a bad person so
and that's what that's what keeps me
coming back to these programs man in the
[ __ ] is lit and it's fun man and every
time I go I get to hear a story that
makes me feel it makes you realize that
I have a heart and then I'm a loving
person because for so much my life I
wanted to know that about myself and now
I go into these rooms and I hear other
people's stories and him and I feel a
certain way in it and there is proof
right there inside of me living inside
of my body through feeling and through
love and that's dope man - it is [ __ ]
dope and so that's kind of where I'm at
man I would um it's 11 p.m. now here on
and I had some calls man look I want to
play one or two calls that came in and
I'm sorry look at you no I'm not sorry
about my story but I'm sorry you know I
had a headache I didn't want to tell
that story tonight um because I wanted
to be able to tell it best as I could
and it's hard to think sometime when
your head is hurting you know but you
know my relationships have gotten better
these days you know my brother and I
mean he's so close to my brother these
days like it's uh you know it's wild you
know and you know and I've met like a
couple of the greatest people I've ever
met like through AAA you know I've
learned about like unconditional love
and things like that not things that I'm
able to practice yet but at least for
the first time in my life you know I'm
aware of some of these things and and
more will be revealed man that's what
they say in that program more will be
revealed you know and you can develop a
relationship with a higher power where
you can do what you want
they got coffee they got shitty cookies
you know it's a [ __ ] trap house but
where people get together to share good
time real time and then look it's just
like the comedy club this weekend man
there you could in one room you could
you probably could have bought a gram in
there but in that other room do we made
some damn magic this weekend but we lit
that [ __ ] on fire and I am uh
I'm grateful to everybody that came out
it's the holidays you know I'm so
excited man I get to go home you know
I'm gonna have a family I have like I
got five nieces and nephews today that
love me you know and even if they don't
I get to watch like my siblings be
parents you know I get to watch my
siblings love their children in a way
that we never got to experience and I'm
awake for that and
and that's cool man that for me man this
[ __ ] is up this [ __ ] is a ride bro
this [ __ ] is a ride so I know this [ __ ]
got a little bit of emo on this episode
and I know it looks like I'm
interrogated this is not an into this is
not an Isis interrogation video if you
look it on YouTube it really looks like
a trap house but um but you know I feel
you know and I don't sometimes they say
you know you're not supposed to talk
about sobriety in a public forum and
stuff like that but whatever man you
know I've never been somebody to break
it up follow really the rules I don't
think and sometimes that's good and
sometimes that's bad but I'm so grateful
to everybody that came out this weekend
because they changed my experience you
know one Thursday I was kind of stress
or Friday I was like oh this place
and by the end I was like man it doesn't
matter where we are you know at our
shows we have a good time and we do it
as you know at a fair price and uh and
I'm grateful man I'm grateful to the
group of people that I get to be a part
of now even in my own shows you know at
our shows we get to do that and I feel
like we're gonna do a lot of cool stuff
in the coming year to help others and
and I just appreciate it man you know
what's interesting too for me is like
this podcast a lot of times even over
the year like maybe there was a time or
two on what I thought on a Saturday
night man I'm gonna get [ __ ] up you
know but then I had to be here for this
podcast on Sunday and so you know I
don't know maybe you know you guys kept
me out of the dark sometimes here and
there and again if your party and you
drinking you getting [ __ ] up if I'm at
your house you're doing coke I don't
care that's fine if y'all shooting up
I'm leaving run okay
if you needle in if you [ __ ] wrote
haystack on your arm and you [ __ ]
needle in yourself I'm out daddy
but if you guys you know your cousin's
on [ __ ] nine tylenol and y'all
blowing a blunt and the G Raja brah I'm
fine you know I don't care if you drink
I don't care if you [ __ ] you know
pour meth down your [ __ ] stepdads
you know esophagus
that's okay you can do with that you
don't have to adjust in your life for me
anything like that people need be
there's nothing you have to be weird
around these kind of people you know my
biggest problem I realized it wasn't
with drugs or alcohol my biggest problem
was with the way that I felt and I am
relieved of some of that and I'm
learning more all the time man and
that's where I'm at you know that's
where I'm at and I'm so thankful that in
a weird way like all those times of
storytelling in line to people and just
you know I just wanted to feel seemed
okay to them you know you know make line
about you know where my dad was or who
he was or you know lying about while I
was walking through somebody's
neighborhood after school because I
didn't even live in that neighborhood
you know and just uh just all kind of
stuff man you know it's interesting
because all that time a story telling
now you know the things that uh that
didn't serve me before now it serves me
now I'm able to go to a place and say
you know and share stories so I mean I
think you know God works in mysterious
ways man and also in